so this month is the sixth year
anniversary of the famous or inFAMOUS
why I left the left video that I did for
prageru you may remember it might be
hard for you to remember but you might
remember that I once was a good Lefty I
was a liberal I was a Democrat all of
those nice things and then things
started to change there were a couple
things that led me to do a video with
prageru one of them of course was that
it seemed to me that my side the left
was actually the ones that were acting
completely illiberately we were the ones
who were silencing free speech on campus
and shouting down speakers we were
focused on the collective instead of the
individual we were silencing voices we
didn't like with false cries of racism
and homophobia and then of course more
than anything else there was the
election of Donald Trump which caused
pretty much everyone I know to go
completely insane that was the backdrop
up to releasing this first video of four
that I did for prageru why I left the
left
Free Speech do you believe that people
should be judged by their character not
their skin color do you believe in
freedom of religion
if you believe these things you're
probably not a progressive you might
think you're a progressive I used to
think I was my show the Reuben report
was originally part of the progressive
Young Turks Network
Progressive struck me as liberals but
louder progressives were the nice guys
they looked out for the little guy they
cared about women and minorities they
embraced change
in short who wouldn't want to be a
progressive
but over the last couple of years the
meaning of the word Progressive has
changed progressives used to say I may
disagree with what you say but I'll
fight to the death for your right to say
it not anymore
Banning speakers whose opinions you
don't agree with from college campuses
that's not Progressive
prohibiting any words not approved of as
politically correct that's not
Progressive putting trigger warnings on
books movies music anything that might
offend people that's not Progressive
either
all of this has led me to believe that
much of the left is no longer
Progressive but regressive this is one
of the reasons I've spent so much time
on my show talking about the regressive
left
this regressive ideology doesn't judge
people as individuals but as a
collective if you're black or female or
Muslim Or Hispanic or member of any
other minority group you're judged
differently than the most evil of all
things a white Christian male the
regressive left ranks minority groups in
a pecking order to compete in a kind of
Oppression Olympics gold medal goes to
the most offended Martin Luther King
Jr's dream that his children would be
judged by their character and not their
skin color was a liberal idea but these
days it's not a progressive ideal and
what about religious freedom the idea
that no one else can tell you what you
have to believe surely progressives
still support that basic right well not
so much I'm a married gay man so you
might think that I appreciate the
government forcing a Christian Baker or
photographer or florist to act against
their religion in order to cater
photograph or decorate my wedding but
you be wrong a government that can force
Christians to violate their conscience
can force me to violate mine if a baker
won't bake you a cake find another Baker
don't demand that the state tell him
what to do with his private business
I'm pro-choice but a government that can
force a group of Catholic nuns literally
called The Little Sisters of the Poor to
violate their faith and pay for
abortion-inducing birth control can
force anyone to do anything that's not
Progressive that's regressive
today's progressivism has become a faux
moral movement hurling charges of racism
bigotry xenophobia homophobia
islamophobia and a slew of other
meaningless buzzwords at anyone they
disagree with
the Battle of ideas has been replaced by
a battle of feelings and outrage has
replaced honesty diversity Reigns
Supreme as long as it's not that pesky
diversity of thought
this isn't a recipe for a free Society
it's a recipe for authoritarianism
for these reasons I can no longer call
myself a progressive I don't really call
myself a Democrat either I'm a classical
liberal a free thinker and as much as I
don't like to admit it defending my
liberal values has suddenly become a
conservative position so if you think
people should be able to say what they
think without being punished for it that
people should be judged by their
behavior not their skin color and that
people should be able to live the way
that they want to live without
government interference then there's not
much left on the left for you
I'll keep trying to explain that to
progressives until I'm totally left out
I'm Dave Rubin of the Rubin report for
Prager University so after that video
blew up and my career blew up pretty
much Western Civilization blew up as
well 17 months later I did my second
video for prageru which was entitled so
you think you're tolerant you may
remember this was around the time that
the tactics of the left of silencing
people and using these false accusations
of racism and homophobia and bigotry not
only were then being used against
conservatives but started to be being
used against old school liberals
themselves guys like Jordan Peterson at
the University of Toronto you may
remember an Infamous moment when Maxine
Waters a Democrat was out there telling
people to get in the face of people she
didn't like there was Candace Owens who
believe it or not was a leftist at the
time and she was hounded out of a
restaurant in Philadelphia and then yeah
the time that little old me went to
University of New Hampshire and they had
to take our event outside of the
University because they couldn't secure
it because I'm so crazy and I got
hounded down and screamed at and things
thrown at me and noise makers and the
rest of it so know the people who
purport to be tolerant often are not the
tolerant ones
tolerance it's a word we hear a lot
these days so let's define it tolerance
is the ability to live with people whose
opinions and behavior you don't agree
with that's essentially how Oxford
defines it how Merriam-Webster defines
it and how we as a society have always
defined it you might be for the death
penalty and your cousin might be against
it you might be against a 15 minimum
wage and your co-worker might be for it
your dad might have voted for Trump your
mom might have voted for Clinton and
your brother may not have voted at all
whatever differences we have tolerating
others opinions is a prerequisite to a
functioning and free society America
itself was built on a foundation of
Tolerance the Declaration of
Independence guarantees us life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness but there
is an implicit contract there to have
your life your Liberty and your Pursuit
of Happiness you have to be tolerant of
somebody else's life their Liberty and
their Pursuit of Happiness this contract
though seems to be breaking down
if you listen to the mainstream media
only one side is living up to this deal
the left the right according to the
media is intolerant of everyone except
those darned white heterosexual
Christian males there's only one problem
it's just not true incredibly the left
isn't even tolerant of the very people
they say they're tolerant of if you're
gay or black or an immigrant and you're
not in lockstep with current leftist
Orthodoxy you know exactly what I'm
talking about if you believe we should
judge people on the content of their
character and not the color of their
skin the left calls you racist if you
believe that America is a nation of
immigrants but that our country should
also protect its borders the left calls
you a xenophobe if you believe that men
and women are equal but fundamentally
different the left calls you sexist
here's the thing those who only tolerate
people they agree with or like are
aren't actually tolerant so who is
tolerant is it the organizers of the
women's March who had to apologize for
the hurt and confusion they caused when
they invited a man left his icon Bernie
Sanders to speak at their convention
is it the anti-fot Thugs who caused UC
Berkeley to spend 600 000 on security
when mainstream conservative Ben Shapiro
showed up to give a talk or is it
democratic congresswoman Maxine Waters
who scolded Kanye West for talking out
of turn when he dared suggest that
blacks should think for themselves these
aren't isolated examples I'm guessing
that you person watching this right now
have silenced yourself because you don't
want to suffer the Wrath of the outrage
mob so let me ask the question again who
is tolerant well here's the surprise
it's actually those scary right-wingers
that the media and the University's
demonize every day I speak from personal
experience maybe I'm a glutton for
punishment here but I still consider
myself a liberal and it's my duty as a
liberal to say what I think I would
rather stand for what I believe and be
hated than bow down and be loved the
left sadly has become come utterly
intolerant of anyone with whom they
disagree why because they believe that
they know how you should live and how
you should think any deviation any
non-conformity is dangerous to that goal
believe it or not the right these days
actually welcomes diversity of thought I
can tell you that in the last few years
of my political Evolution I've
consistently found conservatives to be
tolerant and open-minded don't take my
word for it though test it out for
yourself go talk to some they do exist
and they do things like watch movies
travel and eat ethnic food you know
regular people things
you know what I found out the right much
more than the left believes in the
notion of Live and Let Live and that
ladies and gentlemen is the true
definition of Tolerance I'm Dave Rubin
of the Rubin report for Prager
University
21 months later I did my third video for
prageru The Bravery deficit at this
point wokeness had completely burst
forth into mainstream culture cancel
culture was here people were being fired
left and right and then of course it got
a little rocket fuel which was covid-19
we had lockdowns we had mandates we had
people not being allowed to go to
Grandma's funeral and not being allowed
to go to school and much much more and I
felt the one thing that was going to
stop it was you standing up for yourself
do you watch Fox News with your finger
on the back button in case someone
enters the room
do you methodically clear your browser
history to erase all evidence of prageru
videos do you hide your subscription to
the Ben Shapiro podcast or and perhaps
most dangerous of all are you afraid of
getting caught watching the Reuben
report which is hosted by the very scary
but quite Dapper Dave Rubin
if the answer to any of these questions
is yes then you're in the political
closet and it's time to come out here's
the good news if you currently reside in
the United States of America you live in
the freest country in the history of the
world Beyond some basic limitations you
can do whatever you want and with hard
work become whatever it is you want to
be
pretty great ain't it so why the long
face because you know that something is
out of whack you really don't feel free
to say what you want or share your true
thoughts on Facebook or even associate
with those you'd like to and why is that
I'll tell you why because there's a mass
Affliction spreading throughout the
Western world it's called The Bravery
deficit people good people like you are
afraid to say what they think and
there's Little Wonder believe that men
can't give birth congrats you're a
transphobe want people to keep more of
what they earn because they know how to
spend it better than the government does
Bravo you're a greedy capitalist
understand that the gender pay Gap is
because men and women often choose
different professions and different
hours not because of rampant sexism
hooray you're a misogynist take the
wrong side of any hot button issue and
your reputation your friends and your
job can all be lost in an instant you
will likely never get a chance to
confront your accusers most of whom are
Anonymous and you may feel forced to
issue a faux apology to save yourself
which by the way it usually won't
the understandable temptation is to
think that this politically correct
Madness will soon end just die out on
its own well it won't
activists and their mainstream media
allies like the New York Times and CNN
propaganda Outlets like Media Matters
and the Southern Poverty Law Center and
your local University will make sure of
that big Tech with its control of search
algorithms it's Shadow Banning and
debusting are also in on the game
if you're one of the people who believes
that if you just remain quiet that
things will get better well I hate to be
the bearer of bad news but you're a frog
in a slowly Boiling Pot and it doesn't
end well for the Frog
so what can you do believe it or not the
solution is not that hard step one think
for yourself step two say it out loud
just because a former bartender says the
world is going to end in 12 years
because of climate change doesn't mean
it's true doomsdayers have been saying
the same thing for decades and we're
still here
just because a filmmaker says we should
model our Health Care system on Cuba's
doesn't mean it's a good idea would you
rather have heart surgery in Houston or
in Havana and just because a career
politician is a millionaire with three
houses who rails against the rich
doesn't make him a hypocrite oh wait in
that case it actually does the point is
perhaps your most important job as a
human being is to stand up for the
things you believe in
don't take the path of least resistance
be better than those who would silence
you de-platform you and MOB you how
just stop being afraid
the mob depends on the fact that
everyone is scared to say what they
think don't give them that power all of
the successes of America and the Western
values that gave birth to America are
being eroded as we speak we can't just
blame Hollywood the media and the
political establishment any longer it's
time to look in the mirror
think of The Bravery of your
grandparents and your ancestors before
them who undoubtedly had it far worse
than you do today if they were Brave
then you can be brave too it's time to
come out of the closet the political one
you are the solution to The Bravery
deficit so what are you waiting for I'm
Dave Rubin author of don't burn this
book thinking for yourself in an age of
unreason for Prager University a full
two years later I did my fourth and most
recent video for prageru three ways to
fix America at this point kovid was
somehow still here I guess maybe enough
of us weren't Brave the vaccine mandates
were here we had our Summer of Love
which actually was a summer of violence
we had BLM we had antifa we watched
Cities Burn we watch the media Gaslight
all of us and what I realized more than
anything was maybe rather than figuring
out a new mouse trap we had to go back
to some time-tested ideals
something ain't right and we all know it
are we just gonna give up on the
greatest country in the history of the
world or are we going to fight for
freedom and a thriving future
they always tell us that we're at a once
in a lifetime pivotal moment but this
time they're actually right you know it
I know it you know that I know it I know
that you know it and they know we all
know it so what are we gonna do about it
well I've got a few ideas
first off be an individualist the
American Heritage dictionary defines an
individualist as one that asserts
individuality by independence of thought
and action if that sounds self-centered
it is but why is that bad
everything in your life starts with you
your attitude how you project yourself
to the world whether you take
responsibility for your own actions
the founders of America sought to create
a government whose primary purpose was
to protect the freedom of the individual
after that as far as George Ben and Tom
were concerned you were on your own
nobody saw this more clearly than the
19th century French writer Alexis de
tocqueville he came to America to see
what all the commotion was about and was
absolutely Blown Away
this new American democracy what he
called the equality of conditions was
not merely a new way to govern he
realized but a new way to live for de
tocqueville American individualism was
not about being self-centered but about
being self-reliant government can't
guarantee your happiness but it should
guarantee your right to pursue it this
is the only way to make progress on a
national level and still be
authentically inclusive because where
true Freedom exists there will be
individualism and where individualism
exists there will be true freedom
but being an individualist is just the
start you must also be a family there
are lots of ways to measure the strength
of a society but family has to be at the
top of the list this hit me very deeply
one night during Jordan Peterson's
worldwide lecture tour in 2019 which I
hosted Jordan and I were leaving the
theater after our show in Dublin Ireland
two men ran towards us wiping tears from
their eyes they told us their story they
were a father and son several years
before they had a huge falling out on
their own personal timelines they had
both bought Jordan's Book 12 rules for
life and began fixing up their lives
separately they had attended the show as
thousands of people exited the theater
they saw each other in the crowd and
right then and there after so much time
and so much heartache they embraced and
made amends the family bond was restored
so how important is family according to
a 2019 American Enterprise Institute
survey which asked participants to rank
attributes of the American dream a good
family life ranked number two right
behind Freedom of Choice it's no
surprise it's within the nurturing bonds
of family we learn to deal with the
world once you have your head screwed on
straight and you've made things right
with your family then you're ready to
move on to the next level of real social
Improvement
be a community
there are all kinds of communities it's
your church or your synagogue it's your
neighbors it's the girls you meet for
brunch or the guys you play basketball
with it's the group of people that know
you and care about you and you care
about them next to breathing and maybe a
couple other things I don't know what's
more essential than that
when George Bailey's brother toasts
George at the end of the classic movie
It's a Wonderful Life to the richest man
in town we know exactly what he's
talking about George's Community
are you catching the theme here when
individuals are healthier the family is
healthier and in turn so is society it's
obvious we know it which is why those on
the left oppose all of it every piece
they despise the free thinking
individual they denigrate the family and
they have no true understanding of
community
for the left your identity group your
skin color your sexual preference
determines who you are and how you think
defy this identity at your peril if
you're black and you're conservative
well as one elderly gentleman put it you
ain't black
before they scrubbed it from their
website black lives matter brag that
they were all about deconstructing the
nuclear family you know Mom Dad and the
kids as for Community it's too
independent and too traditional the left
demands that you be part of the
collective a hive mind where everyone
thinks the same anyone outside the hive
mind must be shouted down harassed or
canceled
is that the world you want to be part of
how about this instead be an
individualist be a member of a family be
part of a community you know what that
sounds like to me
America
I'm Dave Rubin author of don't burn this
country for Prager University
so I think you guys can see pretty well
how my political Evolution was laid out
in the course of six years over four or
five minute videos but for me it wasn't
just about learning new ideas and being
unafraid to talk about them it was also
talking to people that I thought were my
ideological enemies whether they were
Dennis Prager or Glenn Beck or Larry
Elder or Jordan Peterson or Ben Shapiro
or the list goes on I was willing to
talk to people hear what they had to say
and then compare that to my own thoughts
I think everything that I've spent the
last couple years talking about is
exactly what is needed in America right
now it's imperfect I'm imperfect you're
imperfect but if we fight for those
ideals and if we act a little bit more
bravely and we turn back to some of
those founding documents that sometimes
seem old and irrelevant I really think
we can fix this thing I look forward to
my fifth and hopeful final prageru video
being something like okay you did it
let's move on that would be pretty sweet
but if you've been on this adventure
with me I appreciate it and I hope
you'll share this with some friends and
and get them on board this little train
that we call Freedom I'm Dave Rubin of
the Rubin report stealing these short
videos from prageru to shoot this film
[Music]